ومع استمرار الاحتجاجات تمديدا بهذه الخطه
خطه نتنياهو لتغيير النظام القضائي يبدو
ان الضغوط السياسيه على نتنياهو تتزايد من
اجل التراجع عن القانون الذي يقول انه
سيحقق توازنا بين دوائر الحكم فبعدما خوف
من عصيان في صفوف الجيش وحرب اهليه حذر
منها الرئيس الاسرائيلي يبدو ان الشقاق
امتد الى داخل حزب اللكود الذي يتزعمه
نتنياهو فبعد انتقاد نادر من وزير الدفاع
ذكرناه حول التعديلات المقترحه وايضا حول
مطالبته بتجميد تمريرها انضم نواب اخرون
من الحزب لدعوه جلنط حيث طلبوا بتعليق
التعديلات في خطوه قد تقود الى احتماليه
تقلص الاغلبيه البرلمانيه التي تحظى بها
الحكومه من المقرر ان يطرح مشروع القانون
في الكنيست للتصديق عليه هذا الاسبوع حيث
يحظى نتنياهو وحلفائه باربعه وستين مقعدا
من اجمالي مقاعد الكنيسه التي يبلغ عددها
120 لكن وجود معارضه من داخل الكود القى
بظلال الشك على ما اذا كان هذا التصويت
الذي لم يتحدد له موعد نهائي بعد سيجري من
الاصل ودعى
النائب عن اللكود ورئيس لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه والدفاع في الكنيست لتعليق
التعديلات القضائيه لاتاحه الفرصه للنقاش
والمراجعه قائلا ان طرح التعديلات للتصويت
قبل ان يتضح وجود دعم لها سيكون مخاطره من
الافضل تجنبها